good morning heck it's tuesday so in
17th century england king charles ii got
a little concerned about all the
political talk brewing over cups of
coffee and cafes you know people were
starting to be like there might be some
downsides to this political system where
the one true ruler is chosen entirely
based on whether his daddy was also the
one true ruler
so king charles ii started this epic pr
campaign against coffee which included
this anonymously written petition
against coffee which reads in part
coffee leads men to trifle away their
time scald their chops and spend their
money all for a little base black thick
nasty bitter stinking nauseous puddle
water now i know that description is
meant to turn the reader away from
coffee but all it makes me want is a
steaming hot cup of puddle water with
which to scald my chops i love coffee it
brings me energy it brings me joy i
really only have three problems with
coffee one if i drink too much of it it
makes me jittery and also i talk too
fast too because it does not arrive at
my house on a regular schedule i
sometimes run out of perfectly roasted
carefully sourced coffee beans and three
the profits of most coffee companies
don't go to charity well the awesome
coffee club cannot solve problem one but
it does seek to solve problems two and
three a few months ago we semi-secretly
launched a coffee company the
testimonials down there are from people
who already signed up the idea is simple
we work directly with small farmers
collectives in the tolima region of
colombia and provide you with awesome
coffee every month or every two weeks
depending on your preference let's start
with the beans and the people who farm
them there are three things that make
awesome coffee different first we know
exactly where the coffee is being farmed
and who is farming it which is
surprisingly rare in the world of coffee
and our sourcing partners at sukafina
make sure to pay those farmers directly
so that money stays in the communities
where the coffee's being grown second
our coffee beans are grown by
communities actively working to
eliminate deforestation which is
essential because coffee is a driver of
deforestation and this project
incentivizes farmers to use
long-standing coffee groves rather than
clearing forests for new ones and lastly
compensation we pay higher than market
rates for awesome coffee beans and also
guarantee a minimum payment even if
market rates drop this increases farmer
income and also allows us to get like
the very best beans our friends at first
crack then roast awesome coffee to a
rich medium dark roast and you choose
whole bean or ground and once a month or
every two weeks awesome coffee shows up
to your home the coffee costs 22 dollars
per bag which includes shipping and you
can cancel at any time no questions
asked if your household like mine drinks
more than 22 cups of coffee per two
weeks then you can order multiple bags
but wait you ask do you ship
internationally alas no at least not for
now explanation in the doobly-doo sorry
here is the best part about the awesome
coffee club all of the prophets are
donated to fight maternal and child
mortality in impoverished communities
not some of the prophets or most of them
all long-term systemic problems need
long-term systemic solutions and our
hope is that the awesome coffee club
like the awesome socks club before it
can provide ongoing long-term support to
charities working to build stronger
healthcare systems starting with the
maternal center of excellence in sierra
we soft launched this spring we've
received so many wonderful pictures and
emails and tweets about the coffee and
it really is the best beans roasted
perfectly we think you'll love it it's
good coffee you can feel good about oh
wait i should probably tell you where
you can get it
awesomecoffeeclub.com link in the
dooblydoo hank i am so nerve-sighted i
hope this works i just made up a word
nerve-sided that's my feeling most of
the time i'll see you on friday